I think the only way to stop drug to
stop pain this book I mean so many
people were in pain sometime they don't
even know why yeah awesome Jed are you
ready to rock do you know doesn't matter
if I don't wear the headphones dear
doesn't have to let him know really
great perfect perfect you don't like
them hear my own voice so what it kind
of makes me kind of self-conscious isn't
it yeah it's good though Johan what made
you decide to be the drug historian
police yeah it was quite personal for me
one of my earliest memories is her
trying to wake up one of my relatives
and not being able to and I was too
young then to understand why but as I
got older I realized we had drug
addiction in my family and when it got
to the point I was doing the research
for this book chasing the screamer eight
years ago now you know I was in this
state where I think a lot of people are
in when they've got someone they loved
with an addiction problem where part of
me was really angry and pissed off and
part of me could see that was totally
not working and in fact there was
another part of me that was really
compassionate and so I ended I wanted to
figure out what I could do so I ended up
going on this big journey all over the
world partly into the history of the war
on drugs but mostly into what's actually
playing out now I wanted to go to the
places that had the most kind of severe
drug policies in the world the places
that had the most compassionate drug
policies in the world so I ended up just
going loads of places and sitting with
loads of different people from kind of
experts to spent a lot of time with a
transgender crack dealer in Brooklyn
who's one of the Brownville that's where
I'm from
yeah yeah if it's ccino ccino harden is
the person i wrote about and got to know
really well ya know grew up very close
to where you grew up - like a hitman for
the deadliest mexican drug cartel - a
scientist here in El
spends a lot of time giving
hallucinogens to animals to see what
happens you know I'd learned that so
much of what we've been told about this
story is is wrong and there's a very
different way of thinking about drugs
addiction the war on drugs the
alternatives to the war on drugs that I
think it's quite exciting to think about
hey darling I just watched you yesterday
on television I did yes what you're
saying you were discussing the rats and
I was saying how do you how do you take
a guy for instance and one of my
situations me and my friend was doing we
were doing cocaine for like what for
like a month but he had to go train
somebody had leave for eight weeks so he
don't do any drugs for eight weeks and
I'm still doing so next time I see him I
mean I was doing cocaine he's a man I
haven't did in six weeks and I said I've
never stopped this is totally one of the
mysteries that was puzzling me right one
of the things that most blew my mind in
what I learned is that we deeply
misunderstood what addiction is right in
exactly the way you were puzzled by this
right so if you had asked me when I
started doing the research on this eight
years ago
what causes for example heroin addiction
right which is something that played out
close to me I would have looked at you
like you were an idiot and I would have
said well the clues in the name dummy
right obviously heroin addiction is
caused by heroin we've been told this
story for a hundred years there's
totally become part of our common sense
so we think if we you know when el
segundo if we stop the next 20 people
who walk past the street on the street
here and we kidnap them and we injected
them all with heroin every day for a
month we think other at the end of that
they'd all be heroin addicts for a
simple reason there are chemical hooks
in heroin that their bodies would start
to desperately physically need right so
they'd have this desperate kind of
physical hunger that's why we call it
being hooked yeah and the first thing
that alerted me to the fact that so not
right about that is when it was
explained to me in Britain where I'm
from obviously if you step out into the
street and you get hit by a truck you
and you break your hip you'll be taken
to hospital and in the hospital you'll
be given loads of a drug called diamine
morphine is heroin right right it's
medically pure hair it's much better
than the [ __ ] you buy round the corner
because it's it's medically pure right
and people in British hospitals are
given that heroin but quite long periods
of time right if anyone watching this
has a British grandmother who had a hip
replacement operation your grandmother's
taken loads of really good heroin right
if what we think about addiction is
right that is just caused by exposure to
the chemical hooks what should be happy
like your friend you know you and your
friend using at the same time what
should be happening to all these people
in British hospitals right right really
significant numbers of them should be
leaving and trying to score on the
streets this has been studied very
carefully it virtually never happens and
when I learned that exactly like the
mystery you were thinking about Mike it
just seems so weird to me I was like
wait so you're saying you could have one
person in a hospital bed who is given
loads of really good heroin and they
don't become addicted and then you've
got someone in the alleyway outside in
it you know Hill on the street using
actually less good heroin who does
become addicted what why would that be
it's the mystery like why was your
friend able to go off and you weren't
right and I only began to understand
this when I went to Vancouver they
interviewed this amazing man called
Professor Bruce Alexander who did a
really important experiment that's
transformed how we think about addiction
and led to some amazing openings around
the world right so professor Alexander
explained to me this story we've got in
our head about addiction the one that
you had when you're sitting there with
your friend the one that I had when I
sit there with my relatives which is
that addiction is caused just by
something in the drug comes from a
series of experiments that were done
earlier in the 20th century you guys
could do the experiments here if you
feel a little bit sadistic right here
you take a rap you put it in a cage and
you give it two water bottles one is
just water the other is water laced with
either heroin or cocaine if you do that
the rat will almost always prefer the
drug water and almost always kill itself
quite quickly right so there's our story
makes perfect sense but in the 70s
professor Alexander came along and said
well hang on a minute you put the rat
alone in an empty cage it's got nothing
that makes life meaningful for rats all
it's got is the drug what would happen
if we did this differently so he built a
cage that he called rat Park which is
basically like heaven for rats right
yeah they got loads of friends
can have loads of sex they got loads of
cheese they got loads of colored balls
anything a rat can want in life and
they've got both the water bottles the
normal water and the drugged water and
of course they try both they don't know
what's in them this is the fascinating
thing in rat Park they don't like the
drugged water they hardly ever use it
none of them ever use it compulsively
none of them ever overdose so when
they're alone and they don't have roads
that make life meaningful 100 percent
compulsive use an overdose if you like
people exactly there's so many human
examples this to me the heart of this
I'm sure we'll talk about lots of human
examples but the main thing I took from
this is the opposite of addiction is not
sobriety the opposite of addiction is
connection right community modes out in
isolation that's profound
isolation is synonymous with addiction
then insulation so isolation is a key
part of it for a lot of people it's more
about I think it's a wider way to
understand that so everyone watching
your show knows they've got natural
physical needs right obviously you need
food you need water you need shelter you
need clean air if I took those things
away from you you've been real trouble
real fast
but there's equally strong evidence that
all human beings have natural
psychological needs right you need to
feel you belong you need to feel your
life has meaning and purpose you need to
feel that people see you and value you
you need to feel you've got a future
that makes sense and our culture's good
at loads of things I'm glad to be alive
today but we've been getting less and
less good at meeting these deep
underlying psychological needs so its
isolation is part of that but it's only
one thought this connection exactly yeah
I went to the first-ever Internet Rehab
Center in the United States it sits
outside Spokane and Washington man it
was kind of funny because I arrived
right it's a clearing in the woods and
the first thing I did totally
instinctively was glance at my phone and
feel really pissed off I couldn't check
my email and I was like oh wait a minute
you're in the right [ __ ] place but
that it was totally fascinating because
I went in there and they get a kind of
hot it's called restart Washington they
get a whole range of people in this
Internet rehab center but they
disproportionately get young men who
become obsessed with multiplayer role
player games like World of Warcraft fort
whatever and and the woman who worked
there only runs it an amazing woman
called dr. Hillary cash said to me
you've got to ask yourself what are
these young men getting out of these
games right every addiction means
something it's not just about the object
of the addiction the core of addiction
is about not wanting to be present in
your life because your life is too
painful a place to be right now helps
you to understand why the war on drugs
is such a [ __ ] disaster because it
imposes more pain on people who are
addicted which far from solving the
problem actually makes it worse but so
we think about this in relation to
social media addiction and it's really
important to think about social media
addiction or other kind of what are
called behavioral addictions like
gambling addiction sex addiction because
they tell us something really important
about the heart of addiction because you
don't if you got to meeting of gamblers
anonymous tonight in LA
they'll be as addicted as anyone in the
Narcotics Anonymous room oh but you
don't snort a roulette wheel
inject a pack of cards right the fact
that you can have all of the addiction
and none of the chemical hooks tells us
how we've overestimated it's not the
chemical hooks aren't real they are real
they do play a role but if you can have
all of it and none of that tells us
something else really important is going
on
so in this Internet rehab center dr.
cash said to me you know think about
these these young men right what are
they getting out of these games they're
getting the things they used to get from
the culture but they no longer get mmm
they're getting a sense of tribe
identity they're getting a sense that
people see them they're getting a sense
they're good at something and they can
get better and better at something
they're getting something as basic as a
sense then roaming around the average
child now spends less time outdoors than
the average maximum security prisoner
because by law a maximum security
prisoner has to have 17 minutes a day
right but what they're getting is more
like a kind of 60 minute in America
slack in here but that but what what
you're what you're getting through this
social media obsession like with all
addiction you're getting like a kind of
parody of it right right like a society
of fulfillment of false sense of tribe
yeah yeah that's totally good way I was
trying to think of an analogy and as I
was there I started to think it's a bit
like I think the relationship between
social media and social life
it's a bit like the relationship between
porn and sex I'm not against porn but if
your whole sex life consisted of looking
at porn you'd be pissed off and
irritable because it didn't evolve to
like wank over a screen we evolved to
have sex yeah in a similar way if too
much of your social life is about these
the kind of talking about people through
a screen yeah that's not if we were
talking through a screen we could have
done this through Skype right yeah if we
were I wouldn't feel I was seeing you
you wouldn't feel you there'll be a
different nature would be nothing yeah
it wouldn't be what we've got now right
definitely and the whole culture is
moved as if we're talking to each other
through Skype all the time right yeah
yeah exactly and I think people are
uncomfortable with being amongst others
for the most part well it's a total
disconnect because you know I mean it's
kind of like the Golden Rule you know we
all want to be treated how you know we
all want to be loved cared about you
know appreciated and treated nicely
right well when we do that to other
people when we lie steal cheat and hurt
other people you mean that's destroying
kind of our self-worth you know because
we don't want to be treated bad we don't
want to be lied to cheated you know
dishonored but we want to be you know
loved and supported so when we're doing
that to other people it's kind of like
you know lowers our self-worth in our
self-esteem
yeah and I think that we're both getting
a really important thing so I heard this
book lost connections I did about why
we're having this epidemic of despair
whether it's addiction depression
anxiety I learned that there's
scientific evidence for nine different
causes of this depression and despair
epidemic
and one of them is absolutely we're
talking about we are the loneliest
Society there's almost like a disease of
unhappiness exactly way it really is
there's a study that asks Americans
how many close friends do you have you
could turn to in a crisis and when they
started doing this years and years ago
the most common answer was five today
the most common answer is none right
there are more people or no one to turn
to when things go wrong than any other
option and as human beings we evolved to
live in tribes right yeah community why
are we here why do we exist because our
ancestors on the savannahs of Africa
were really good at one thing they
weren't faster than the animals they
down
they weren't bigger than the animals
they took down they were much better at
banding together into tribes and
cooperating just like bees need a hive
humans need a tribe and we are the first
humans ever to try to disband our tribes
and it makes us feel like [ __ ] you think
about the circumstances where we evolved
if you were cut off in the tribe you
would depressed and anxious for a really
good reason you were probably about to
die right those are the impulses we have
and it's been very striking to me to see
the places that I've tried to build
responses to say the addiction or
depression crisis around understanding
these insights so I'll give you an
example in Portugal in the year 2000
they had one of the worst drug problems
in the world right 1% of the population
was addicted to heroin which is
incredible and every year they tried the
American Way more they arrested more
people they imprisoned more people they
[ __ ] up more people and every year the
problem got worse and one day the Prime
Minister and the leader of the
Opposition got together and they're like
look we can't go on like this right what
are we gonna do they decided to sub
panel of scientists and doctors right
and they said led by an amazing man I
got to know good doctor Wow cool ow
he said look you guys go away figure out
what would genuinely solve this problem
and we've agreed in advance we'll do
whatever you recommend right she just
took it out of politics so they go away
they look at loads of evidence including
rat Park what we were talking about and
they came back and they said
decriminalize all drugs from cannabis to
crack everything but and this is the
crucial next step take all the money we
currently spend on [ __ ] people up
yeah on chasing them arresting slightly
amazing what you do try to stop this
happening
arresting people imprisoning people take
all that money and spend it instead on
turning their lives around and
interesting Lee it's not quite what we
think of his drug treatment in the US so
they do a bit of residential rehab that
has real value biggest thing they did
was a massive program of reconnection so
say you used to be mechanic they'll go
to a garage and they'll say if you
employ this guy for a year we'll pay
half his wages right it's a program
where gay people live mmm yeah they're
much cheaper than sending them to prison
right or a program of small loans so
people with addiction problems
set up businesses with their friends
about things they thought were important
right the goal was to say to everyone
with an addiction in Portugal we love
you we value you we're on your side we
want you back right and by the time I
went to Portugal this had been in place
for 13 years and the results were
totally clear addiction was down by more
than 50% overdoses were down by more
than 80% that's it for one of the ways
you know it works so well is that almost
no one in Portugal wants to go back I
went and interviewed and the guy who led
the opposition to the decriminalization
at the time it was a top cop in Portugal
drug cop
it's called quire Guerra and he said to
me so at the time he'd said you know and
what a lot of people think when you talk
about decriminalizing or drugs right
surely we'll have an explosion and drug
usually will have chaos and drug madness
exactly a lot of people said bro and you
can understand why right he said to me
everything I said would happen didn't
happen and everything the other side
said would happen did and at some point
when it comes to say addiction we have
to start what we've been doing up to now
is copying all the places that have
failed right the one thing you can say
in defense of the American war on drugs
is we gave it a fair shot right we've
done it for a hundred years trillion
dollars we have killed a conservative
estimate hundreds of thousands of people
we've destroyed whole countries like
Colombia and at the end of that we can't
even keep drugs out of our prisons and
where we pay someone to walk around the
[ __ ] wall the whole time yeah good
luck keeping them out of the whole
country this is a fantasy we have to
start copying the places that have
succeeded not the places that have
failed well that's what happens to is
when you know and we need compassion
instead of punishment
you know when you're doing you know when
people are trapped in interdiction you
know when I was trapped in my addiction
and I kept getting punished over and
over and over and then what you're
talking about a tribe you mind going to
prison and when you're there you're
gonna find your tribe where it's okay to
lie steal cheat manipulating hustle and
all this kind of stuff and so now
there's no compassion there's no support
there's no you know and that and that's
a big misconception - is it you know
when people are trapped interdiction
they think that you know it's their
choice you know they all just make a
decision to stop using but when you're
trapped in that thing it's no longer
it's no longer a choice and one of the
big things is you know we punish
ourselves and we're trapped we see our
world is going to pieces and going to
crap we see it it's clear as day and we
don't like it either
you know the addict doesn't like it
either and they know they're suffering
but now we're getting punished even
worse when we're already hard on
ourselves and right everyone's punishing
us so that does not help at all you know
kill yourself yeah well you know it's
suicide depression these things are way
up in our country well I think Mike you
make a really important point it's not
just think about the opioid crisis right
it's not a coincidence that the opioid
crisis is at its worst
in the places where it's suicide without
opiates is at its worst where
antidepressant prescription is at its
worst right we've got a crisis of deep
despair in this culture right and my
worry about the opioid well there's many
things I'm worried about the opioid
crisis so for the first time in the
entire history of the United States
average white male life expectancy is
falling outside a war right that's an
incredible thing right and and one thing
that really worries me about that the
way we're talking about the opioid
crisis is up to now people have been
fixating on the drug itself right and
there is a problem with the drug itself
but we've got if you want to understand
why people are using so many painkillers
you've got to understand why they're in
such deep pain in the first place right
and - and if we just take away the drug
what in fact happens and you consist in
Oklahoma interviewed a guy called dr.
house who's shown this with his patients
if you just cut people off who are
addicted
what happens they go to the street and
buy heroin and they're much more likely
to die so we're actually in this this
did this disastrous situation we've got
to look at the places that have actually
solved opioid crises right so I'll tell
you about one of them because it cuts
some of these things so in Switzerland
my dad's from there so I'm a citizen
today in Switzerland they had a massive
heroin and opioid crisis in the 90s
right and it was just a [ __ ] horror
show like what's happening now in the US
and they tried what we're doing now
which is punishing people restricting
the drug all of that
I just kept deaths kept going up and
then they finally got this incredible
female president called Ruth Dreyfus as
she explained to people
when you hear the word legalization what
you picture is like anarchy and chaos
what we have now is anarchy and chaos
right we have unknown criminals selling
unknown chemicals to unknown untreated
drug users all in the dark all filled
with violence and disease so what she
proposed was legalizing herre which
sounds quite shocking when you hit right
obviously no one is proposing legalizing
heroin like cannabis no one thinks there
should be like a heroin aisle in CVS
that's not the plan right yeah the way
it worked was if you had a heroin
problem you were assigned to a clinic I
went to the one in Geneva the former
president lives opposite this clinic
which I think tells you something right
you go in mmm you assigned to the clinic
you go in at 7 o'clock in the morning
because Swiss people believe in doing
things ridiculously early you go in
you're given your heroin there it's
medically pure heroin you can't take it
out with you you have to use it there a
nurse will watch you while you use it
and then you leave to go to your job
because they give you help to get work
and they give you help to get therapy
and they give you help to get housing
and and what's incredible to look at the
results right there have been zero
heroin overdose deaths on the lingual
heroin program in 15 years since it
began right not one person has died and
there's been an enormous but Swiss
people are super conservative right my
Swiss relatives make Trump look like
Oprah and yet Swiss people after this
had been in place for two years they had
a referendum on it and 70% of Swiss
people voted to keep it legal because
crime fell so much right because when
you deal with addiction the knock-on
effects for the whole water community
for but one of things that really
surprised me in in the Swiss program so
in that program if you're on it they
will give you any dose of heroin you
want except for one that would kill you
and there is never any pressure to cut
back but almost everyone does cut back
overtime and stop and I member saying to
the psychiatrist who runs the program
Rita Maggie well why is that right
because we're told the drug takes you
over there's nothing you can do she said
to me well we help them so their lives
get better and as your life gets better
you don't want to be anesthetized so
much Roe which seems almost stupid but
think about that in comparison to the
opioid crisis what we do so Switzerland
do they do two things give the person
the drug give them massive amount of
support to figure out why they want the
drug so that over time they won't want
it what we're doing is
the opposite we take away the drug and
instead of giving them support we give
them criminal records exactly what you
you know you're doing the icing work on
this criminal records we put barriers
between them and reconnecting and you
know Switzerland is the country that
solved the crisis what's happening here
it's getting worse and worse and worse
well that's the thing when when you're
on heroin you know every heroin addict
when you're strung out on heroin you
don't want to be on heroin but you can't
figure out a way out you know and to get
out you know there's all these you know
programs but they're expensive to get
into and there's a waiting list and then
you know when you wind up getting in
trouble like every heroin addict doesn't
want to be a heroin addict but there's
no there's not a lot of solution out
there so that's what you know that's why
I can see how that works very well
because they're giving them some
solution they're saying hey look it you
don't have to cut back but then when you
have the option like yes I want to cut
back and the majority of them start to a
recovery that's wonderful and it's what
I love that I love the work you're doing
okay because yeah your your work is all
about love and connection super
importance is something I saw everywhere
don't give up on people
exactly you know dr. Gabbe Marte who's a
really great expert on this said to me
if making people suffer reduced
addiction there wouldn't be a in the
world right but but but we've got we've
got a whole system that is based on so
sometimes people say Oh punishing
addicts doesn't work right the treat is
much worse
punishing addicts makes that makes these
makes it worse I would have an Arizona
with edge waited 100% out yes I went out
in Arizona with a group of women who
were made to go out on a chain gang
wearing t-shirts saying I was a drug
addict
while members of the public mocked them
jeered at them then they go back to live
in tents right with the earth in their
tent are you been to tent city tell me
about what happened when you tell us
about the current state okay I got
pulled over in a head and cocaine in my
possession oh so ever since - one day
one day one day
yeah what was that like it was just
really hot like um get take clothes off
15 degrees out there that's brutal ma'am
and the guy who runs that and they make
you have you yam trouble yeah they make
you unchanging no so you have to what do
you do on the chain gang people houses
up or their property they're both fixed
some corporation up well they make them
dig graves some of them yeah yeah heard
that well what you think about those
women right so this is this is a prison
run by Sheriff Joe Arpaio who was later
shown to be himself a criminal have
engaged in racist profiling of Latinos
while there was actually a rapist going
around killing huge numbers raping loads
of women in in in that part of Arizona
he didn't dedicate any resources to that
he dedicated towards racist harassment
of Latinos and then when he was revealed
to be a criminal
president Trump pardoned him but that
that if we think about what's happened
with what happens there in those
situations right what happens
those women are even more traumatized
and even more [ __ ] up when they leave
yeah yeah I'm solving their addiction
and sitting with those women and the men
in that prison as well I just kept
thinking because I'd already I think
been to Portugal and Switzerland just
thinking [ __ ] hell if we were in
Portugal in Switzerland you could be
helped back to a healthy decent life
right that's what you deserve that's
what you need and what are we doing
we're we're shaming and brutalizing and
this goes right back to the origins of
the war on drugs you talked a bit Mike
about their the history of this right
the place where I open my book chasing
the screen at first it might seem like a
slightly weird place to begin a story
about the one drugs you might think
what's this got to do with the drug war
bitties tells us about the absolute
heart of it so in in in the spring of
1939 in midtown Manhattan Billie Holiday
walked on stage in a hotel and she sang
for the first time a song that I'm
pretty sure everyone listening to this
will know it's a song called strange
fruit right it's a song about lynching
it's this idea that the lynched bodies
of african-american men in the south are
like the strange fruit of the South
right now and that night Billie Holiday
got a warning
from a man called Harry Anslinger who
ran the Federal Bureau of Narcotics and
the warning said basically stop singing
this song right and it seems like a
weird place to begin a story about the
worn drugs what's this got to do with
the drug war it's the absolute [ __ ]
heart of it right so Harry Anslinger was
a government bureaucrat who takes over
the department of prohibition just as
alcohol prohibition is ending so he's
got this big government department and
it's got nothing to do right about to
have nothing to do and he invented the
modern war on drugs and he builds it
around to cuz most drugs were legal at
that time and he champions the banning
of it banning of cannabis/marijuana
Turks exactly exactly and and and he
builds the war on drugs around to really
intense hatreds that he had of which
Billie Holiday is like the perfect
example he really hated
african-americans and Latinos I mean he
was so racist that he was regarded as a
crazy racist in the 1920s right he used
the n-word so often in official police
memos his own senator said he should
have to resign and the other group he
hated violently hated was
african-american people with addiction
problems right and Billie Holiday is an
African American standing up to white
supremacy and she had a text she had
been horrific aliy raped when she was a
little girl she was in fact raped for
money in a brothel by countless men she
was dealing with the pain and trauma
that by a very heavy heroin use and when
Harry Anslinger says stop singing this
song Billie Holiday effectively says
[ __ ] you I'm an American citizen
yeah I'll sing what I damn well please
and that is when Harry Anslinger
resolved to destroy her so he hated
employing african-americans but you
couldn't really send a white guy into
Harlem to stalk Billie Holiday we got
obvious say important African American
agent called Jimmy Fletcher whose job
was to follow Billie Holiday around for
two years and document her drug use but
Billie Holiday was so amazing that Jimmy
Fletcher fell in love with her and his
whole life he really regretted what he
did so he arrests her she's put on trial
the trial was called the United States
vs Billie Holiday and Billie Holiday
said that's how it [ __ ] felt and she
sent to prison for 18 months she doesn't
sing a word in prison but the cruelest
thing is what happened next right she
gets out and at that time to sing
anywhere
new card exactly a cabaret performers
like forth exactly and they made sure
she didn't you need to perform anywhere
in New York and most big cities they
made sure she didn't get it was one of
her friends your land above Ann said to
me what is the cruelest thing you can do
imagine taking away singing from Billie
Holiday yeah right there's a word in
that situation of course she relapsed
right so she goes back into quite heavy
heroin and alcohol use one day she
collapses in in in Midtown actually not
far from where she'd first performed
strange fruit the first hospital
wouldn't even tank her cause she had an
addiction problem second hospital agreed
to take her but on the way in she was
convinced Ann sling his men weren't
finished with her she said to her friend
Meili Duff T they're gonna kill me in
there
don't let them they're gonna kill me she
was right they are so in the hospital
she was diagnosed with advanced liver
cancer and she starts to go into
withdrawal because she's obviously she's
not given any heroin there and
withdrawal is painful at any time but if
you're very weak with liver cancer it
can kill you so her friend Meili Duffy
managed to insist they gave her
methadone so she started to recover and
they came and arrested her on her
hospital bed they change they handcuffed
her to her hospital bed they didn't let
her friends in to see her they took away
her candies right and then they cut off
the the methadone was cut off and the
next day she died as one of her friends
put it and she looked like she had been
violently wrenched from life right but
to me there's several things to learn
about especially you see what the war on
drugs has been about from the start
right
making addicts lives worse racist
persecution of african-americans and
Latinos we know and still today
African Americans are no more likely to
use or sell drugs than any other group
they make up the vast majority of people
who are imprisoned for it arrested and
imprisoned Laurie but also the same even
more important that I learn from this
story which is and it helped me with
some of the people I love you've got
addiction problems right no matter what
they did to her Billie Holiday always
found somewhere to sing that song she
would go to the worst parts of the deep
south where they [ __ ] threw bottles
at her on the stage she sang strange
fruit right and sometimes I think with
addiction in this culture we tell one
heroic story about people with addiction
problems and it's a real story which is
they stopped being addicted that oh they
recover right but you know Billie
Holiday never stopped being addicted
right she was still a hero
all over the world everyday people
listen to Billie Holiday and they feel
stronger right so that continuing and
fighting and persisting even when you
are being persecuted and beaten down and
that's a form of heroism right and I
think you must see this every day with
the work they do with homeless people
tell me about yeah man
tell us about standing united that was
[ __ ] amazing about Billie Holiday by
the way that was amazing well you know
we go out there I mean you know I
struggled with addiction heroin
addiction for years and also meth and
alcohol and just everything else and
then been in in and out of prison and uh
you know seven years ago you know how
you were talking about community you
know seven years ago a community you
know that's kind of the program you know
they you know took me picked me up you
know I got involved in the program it
met some other people and basically
that's what helps like with the program
is a you know community of people and
then being accountable to people and
also having goals and objectives and
dreams and things to hope for and a lot
of times you know when I was out there
stuck you know how you're talking about
the cage you know when you're in this
cage you know that's what it seems like
it seems like all your options are taken
away and you can't see anything so all
your options and so you just wind up
stuck in this culture and then plus you
know all the shame and all the guilt and
all the disappointment and everything
just sticks with you so you wind up you
know perpetuating this thing and you
keep going back to the drugs and the
alcohol so you know I haven't found the
way out and then I became an
interventionist and a counselor and you
know working with addicts and alcoholics
and I see that you know we need some
love and some compassion for people that
are stuck you know and I talk with
parents all the time and the problems is
when we're stuck we don't know right
from wrong up from down you know you
make a decision one second and then you
change your decision you know that's one
of the one of the examples of they talk
about an addict or a non addict and they
say like a non addict you know like
house you know like my brother you know
my brother dabbled in drugs and you know
alcohol and like he never got stuck in
it you know he went up recognizing hey
this isn't gonna work
not gonna have a family at home a career
if I keep messing with this stuff so he
just stopped you know so so one example
is like a non addict or a non alcoholic
let's say they'll have hopes and dreams
and goals in life and things that they
want to achieve so they're able to
change their behavior to be able to
reach those goals they'll say look at
I've been drinking way too much I've
been using and partying way too much I'm
not gonna get the career the house the
family the kids if I keep doing that so
they'll change their behavior an addict
or an alcoholic
you know the hopeless variety that we
keep a perpetuating this thing what we
do is we wind up changing our goals but
not our behavior you know so we'll say
you know I didn't want that house I
didn't want that relationship I didn't
want this thing but I'm not gonna change
my behavior because that's the only
thing that seems satisfying at the time
and it just keeps going in this vicious
cycle so now what we do is having been
there I understand what they're going
through well you know when they tell me
you know you don't know how I feel you
don't know what I'm going through
yes I do I know exactly how you feel and
I know exactly what you're going through
and then some build some rapport and
also like I never give up on people
that's super important like I have a lot
of families they talked to us and they
say how can you be so patient with you
know Jimmy hasn't Jimmy has fallen apart
a hundred times and you've worked with
them how can you be so patient because
I've fallen apart a thousand times and
it was that one thousand and one time
that I wind up making it so I don't know
when someone's gonna get it but I keep
working with people and I keep pulling
you know and then the homeless you know
the homeless that are out there they
don't want to be homeless and the
addicted out there they don't want to be
addicted and strung out they need some
solution so that's what we do is we work
with a lot of different employers out
there we work with a lot of different
programs out there and outreach stuff
and you know we pull these people out of
that the people that want help we want
to be there we are there when someone
raises their hand they say I want to
change you know I'll get them get them
either into a detox or a program or get
them into a sober living and then
have we work with numerous employers
that will give these guys a shot you
know they'll give them a shot they'll
say okay look it here's a job here
here's where you gonna live here's a job
here's food
here's clothes here's a resume we're
giving you everything you need it's
awesome and sometimes they do fall apart
you know I mean that's just part of the
process sometimes they'll do they will
fall apart in a week two weeks three
weeks and maybe they have to go back out
there but I always tell them I'm like
you know what I'm never gonna give up on
you ever yeah I'm never you know so just
keep coming back and then they'll call
me in a few weeks they'll call me in a
month because I always want to make sure
that door is always open because if I
get down on them or get angry or upset
with them and tell me you know what you
screwed up I'm tired of this when
they're in their darkest moment they
won't make that call they won't call us
back they'll say you know what they love
me they supported me and I'm always
welcome back let me ask you guys
something because and just hear your
thoughts on it
you know I come from a family that has
been that has been affected by the
disease of alcoholism and you know in in
the program you know they talk about
alcoholism and I really believe you know
to the broader discussion of addiction
you know as this disease a-thinking
disease you know so what is it that you
know it's I guess it's a matter of
circumstances really that you know
creates and one individual and ability
to put the substances down and then in
another instance you know where the
substance becomes something that that
individual leans on or goes to to find
that connection you know what do you
guys think about that so this I
obviously went to interview loads of
expert the kind of leading experts in
the world on this and it's important it
comes back to what Mike said right at
the start and this surprised me because
it wasn't my family's experience but
actually even if we look at the drugs
that are the most demonized drugs things
like crack actually the evidence is
quite clear that the vast majority
people even who use crack who try crack
do not become addicted to it right so
everyone knows if we went into a bar
here in El Segundo tonight and we look
around there will be some people who are
alcoholics there who need our love and
support but the vast majority of people
there are actually just using the
alcohol because it makes you know
they're chilling out or it makes their
life better right it turns out it's
slightly higher for some drugs but for
all drugs most users do not become
addicted nice I think with us in fact
the the UN Office of Drug Control who
are the main drug war body in the world
even they admitted 90 percent of all
currently banned drugs don't cause
addiction and don't harm people's house
it's like well what's going on what how
what exactly the question you're asking
even what why a ninety percent people
able to do it and ten percent not and
with all mental health problems that my
oh it's depression schizophrenia
dementia anything and turns out there's
three kinds of cause right and they play
out to some degree in everyone so
there's biological causes right like
your genes real changes in your brain
those are very real right there's
psychological causes which are how you
think about yourself like you're talking
about is changing digital pointment
exactly and then this environmental
causes some of the things we've talked
about loneliness and I go through and
lots of other ones in my book lost
connections so obviously they play out
in different ways in each individual
rights are some people there will be you
know a heavily psychological component
some people are heavily social component
but what we've got to do is deal with
all three right we've got we've got to
have strategies that deal with all three
of these if we can and I think just
focusing on one simplifies the problem
right if you've got it you've got to see
this in the more complicated way and
you've got a look at places that so I'll
give you an example of place that tried
this with depression which I think is
very interesting although it hasn't been
tried with addiction I think it would be
an interesting experiment so there was a
write based on my book loss connections
so there's this doctor in East London
called Sam evering Tim he said just a
general doctor right and he was really
uncomfortable because he had a loads of
patients coming to him with terrible
depression and anxiety right and like me
he thinks there's some role for chemical
antidepressants but I could also see
most people who was giving them too were
becoming depressed again after a while
and it could also see that they were
depressed for totally understandable
reasons right for example they were
really lonely that's one of the examples
so he
decided to try a different approach one
day a woman came to see him called Lisa
Cunningham who'd been shut away in her
home with just crippling depression and
anxiety for seven years and he said to
Lisa
don't worry I'll carry on giving you
this drug I'm also going to prescribe
something else there was an area behind
the doctor's surgery that was known as
[ __ ] alley which gives you a sense of
what it was like just kind of scrub Lam
and dogs and go Sheriff he said what I
want you to do is come and turn out
twice a week I'm gonna come to because
I've been quite anxious we're gonna meet
with another group of depressed and
anxious people we're gonna turn [ __ ]
alley into something nice right first
time the group met Lisa was literally
physically sick with anxiety but as the
group met they decide what can we do
they decided they were gonna learn
gardening right these are inner-city
East London people don't know [ __ ] all
about gardening right start to teach
themselves gardening they started to get
their fingers in the soil they started
to learn the rhythms of the seasons
there's loads of evidence interacting
with the natural world is a really
powerful antidepressant you need that as
a human being but they also did
something else goes back to what you've
said before Evan they started to form a
tribe right they start to care about
each other if one of them didn't turn up
someone were going be like what's up
right they started to solve each other's
problems and the way Lisa put it to me
as the garden began to bloom we began to
bloom there was a study of a very
similar program found it was more than
twice as effective as giving people
chemical antidepressants right I think
for an obvious reason saying I saw all
over the world the most effective
strategies for dealing with depression
anxiety and addiction are the ones that
deal with the reasons why we feel so
[ __ ] in the first place and if you tell
people a story that it's just a problem
in their brain what that does is it says
to them your depression doesn't your
pain doesn't mean anything right it's
like a glitch in a computer program and
the most important thing we can explain
to people is your pain makes sense you
feel this way for a reason you're not
crazy if you're depressed if you're
anxious if you're addicted you're not
crazy you're not a machine with broken
parts you're a human being with unmet
needs and what you need is practical
love and support to get those needs met
I love that man I love that idea and
people need to I mean it's great to
become aware to this you know this type
of this way of thinking about addiction
what do you think this sort of
psychological paradigm is in America
maybe in other countries in the world as
well of demonizing these addicts where
does it come from
like what is this you know shaming
driven sort of culture we've created or
that has been created what is it what's
the root of that I think it's a mixture
of things and I don't feel totally
confident in the answer to this cuz I
think there's things in it we don't
understand but I think part of it is in
fact natural right like I think about
the people I love you've got addiction
problems I'm still quite angry with them
a lot at the time right I think one of
the reasons why the debate about the war
on drugs is so charged it's because
actually runs through the hearts of all
of us we've all got a little Harry
Anslinger in our head that's going to
stop you stop you why is it someone
stopping you why are you doing this and
we've all got unless we're totally crazy
a kind of loving compassionate part in
us and there's a in a way this is a
conflict that plays out in all of us I
also think you know look there's a huge
bureaucracy built around this war and
it's looking for targets it's looking
for enemies let's think about the
banning of cannabis right which I know
you guys obviously care about a lot yeah
so cannabis is banned in the 1930s and
it's banned using this this this this
campaign so Harry Anslinger this guy I
was talking about wants to keep his
department going and at that time heroin
and cocaine were banned but they were
really minor tastes in the United States
there weren't very many people you
couldn't keep a big department going but
around that so he decides he'd said
previously that cannabis was not harmful
shouldn't be banned suddenly he
announces it's he said was literally the
worst drug in the world
he said if Frankenstein's monster bumped
into cannabis on the stairway
Frankenstein's monster would drop dead
that was great right he said he starts
creating these crazy stories so one of
my favorite things he did it was go
through his stuff in his archives was
really funny he said to his agents so I
want you to go and gather information
about the harm cannabis does right so he
would go to these jazz clubs the agents
would go to these jazz clubs and they
would write down the lyrics of jazz
songs and they thought that they were
literally true so there's a song called
bat
man that says when he gets the notion he
thinks he can walk across the ocean and
the agent writes cannabis makes you
believe you can walk across the ocean
people drown right so he draws Lusa and
then this crime happened so in Florida a
boy called Victor like Arthur who was 21
hacked his family to death with an axe
and Harry has it with the kind of help
of her snoop Hearst Newspapers which was
like the kind of Fox and news of the day
wrote Harry Anslinger announces this is
what will happen if you smoke cannabis
you hack your family to death with an
axe years later someone goes back and
checks this boy didn't even smoke
cannabis he'd been seriously mentally
ill his family have been trying to get
him into a psychiatric hospital for
years
and the but this kind of crime is used
as a kind of hysteria and in the wake of
ear Anslinger bands cannabis and we we
are where we are now although it's
starting to fall apart after you know
more than 70 years of destroying
people's lives in this insane war at
least cannabis prohibition is is falling
apart but you can see how you can see so
there's a range of things going on in
answer to a question Evan there's
bureaucratic interests invested in
keeping us misinformed
there's genuine and understandable fears
and anxieties and there are real harms
that come from some drugs there are real
benefits loads of people's lives are
made better by smoking weed by some
people's lives that get through a
terrible time by using very powerful
anesthetics and there are harms and we
need to have an honest conversation
about that if you just focus on the
harms actually if you focus on the harms
in this simplistic way you end up making
the harms even worse yeah well what
happens to is it you know when someone's
using drugs like heroin or speed or you
know cocaine and they're using it like
that I mean they're acting very erratic
so the solution that most people think
is just get them to stop somehow punish
them get them take that stuff away and
they should be able to act well and be
okay without that stuff but then when
you take that stuff away you that person
is not the spirit still sick because
there's something inside of us that when
we're acting that way that's compelling
us to do something that we know is not
healthy so you just take that stuff away
so now we're even like even worse all
what are we doing now what do we do you
know there's this old analogy that
says if you take away if you sober up a
drunken horse thief what do you have mmm
a sober horse thief I love you cuz you
got a change we got to work on that we
got to understand be more compassionate
we have to understand what they're going
through why they're doing what they do
why we do what we do you know and
there's need some you know some
counselling some therapy some you know
some processing that hasn't go on you
know there's some kind of inside change
if you're understandably based on a
personal experience in this amazing what
you did but yeah that was one person who
helped me to think about this a bit
different at Sheila's they keep it in
relation to depression but I think it
relates a lot to what you're saying I
went to interview this South African
psychiatrist for lost connections called
Derrick Sommerfeld and he was in
Cambodia in 2001 when in that country
they introduced chemical antidepressants
for the first time right and the local
doctors the Cambodian doctors didn't
know what they were so like well what
are NT des personnes and he explained
and they said to him I wouldn't need
them we've already got antidepressants
and he said what do you mean he thought
they were going to talk about some kind
of like herbal remedy like st. John's
wort instead they told him a story
there was a farmer in their community
who worked in the rice fields and one
day he stood on a landmine and got his
leg blown off so they gave him an
artificial leg and he went back to work
in the rice fields after a while right
but apparently it's super painful to
work underwater with an artificial leg
I'm guessing it's traumatic for obvious
reasons guy starts to cry all day
doesn't want to get outta bed develop
classic depression right so the doctor
said to some of her well that's when we
gave him an antidepressant and he said
what was it they explained that they
went and sat with him they listened to
him they realized that his pain made
sense it had a cause they figured if
they bought him a cow he could become a
dairy farmer he wouldn't be in this
position that was [ __ ] him up so they
bought in Macau within a couple of weeks
his crying stopped within a month his
depression was gone they said to dr.
Summerfield so you see doctor that fat
cow that was an antidepressant that's
what you mean right now if you've been
taught to think about these problems the
way we have it so I went to my doctor
for an antidepressant he gave me a can
but what those Cambodian doctors knew
intuitively is what the leading molecule
body in the world the World Health
Organization has been trying to tell us
the years we feel this way for a reason
right this isn't some [ __ ] irrational
glitch we feel like this because our
needs are
being met because there's trauma or a
whole range of things amazing stuff you
work with and if you understand that in
a different way that in a way the
question we've got to be asking is well
what's the cow for the things that are
making us feel this way right
that's awareness you know aware and
understanding it's very important and
once you shift your perspective in that
way solutions become clearer to you you
just can't see if you've been told like
I when I went to my doctor with
depression when I was a teenager my
doctor was like oh there's just a
problem in your brain right that when
you're lacking a chemical called
serotonin in your brain that's why you
feel this way right and it's not there's
no truth there are biological
contributions to depression obviously
but that just cut me off from thinking
about how can I change my life how can I
get help with we tell these it's the
same with if you tell people with an
opioid problem it's just the drug that
did this to you
this evil drug right we need to get rid
of this evil drug right it's off
standing on what's so wild is every time
I got so because I have many attempts at
sobriety
you know many attempts and every time I
always thought in my head that if I just
get off of this stuff I'm gonna be happy
Joyce and free you know and every time I
got off of it I was just white knuckling
stone cold sore and miserable yeah you
know and I would stay sober just long
enough until I wind up relapsing you
know this last time through you know
being fulfilled with community support
achievement jobs and all that you know
I'm being able to process all the things
that were going on inside you know it's
a process of change has to come from
within you know you can't just take away
the drugs and say okay you're gonna be
awesome now because that's not the
solution you know there needs to be some
community some processing some you know
some goals some objectives and no the
can get through that the cow is really
symbolic of bringing back connection to
that guy's life and being heard being
communicated to but also reestablishing
a new purpose for him because now he
didn't have to go toil in the rice
fields he could now you know be a dairy
farmer
he reinvented himself through that cow
Mike would you say cannabis is your cow
always back to my cow
yes these guys trying to make a big
business I guess tamale make no money
out of it yeah yeah yeah exactly I mean
what do you think about that Johann the
just the the amount of money that's
being pushed into our government from
these pharmaceutical companies yeah
weirdly I've become friends with Pablo
Escobar's son I think I you guys should
meet him he's an Iranian he's an
extraordinary
said to me I saw him in Buenos Aires a
little while ago he said the only thing
my father feared was drug legalization
he said if drugs had been illegal my dad
would have been a car salesman you would
never have heard his name well right and
and if you think about so if we think
about the I would have stress I don't
think this is the main reason why drugs
continued to be banned I can talk about
what I think the main reason isn't in a
minute but there are definitely vested
interests involved in keeping the drug
war going if you want to see what they
are it's pretty easy just Google who
funds the anti legalization campaigns
when cannabis legalization is on the
ballot generally it's the prison guard
unions the alcohol companies they don't
want a big commercial competitor
understandable they don't want their own
and kind of religious groups who don't
have a financial interest but it just
quite as its some sort of moral and so
if we want to and so there's probably
that I don't think that's the main
reason why it carries on being League I
think the main reason is most Americans
if you say do you think the war on drugs
has succeeded or failed huge majority
say it's failed right more than eighty
percent yeah ah people are frightened
about the alternatives mmm they think
that if you're in favor of legalization
you're in favor of selling to children
in fact the exact [ __ ] opposite right
if drugs are controlled by criminals
they don't care whether they sell to
your children if you want your children
to be protected from I mean I hate to be
this guy called Fred Martin's here is an
extremely right-wing cop in New Jersey
not you know pretty hearty reminded me
of the Clint Eastwood character and
Dirty Harry
but he had this moment that changed his
mind about the war on drugs and who's
kind of unexpected ally in this so one
day in the early 70s he was staking out
a dealer in plain clothes in a in a in a
car park in Wayne New Jersey and so he's
in plainclothes he's watching the guy at
the dealer and a kid comes up to him and
says hey mister will you go into that
liquor store and buy me some booze I'm
not allowed to run too young and and he
said no [ __ ] off you know I'm not doing
that so the kid walked up to the dealer
and bought some drugs from him instead
because the dealer doesn't care they're
not grants the ID right and Fred had
this epiphany he wouldn't put it in such
a fancy term but legalization puts a
regulatory barrier between sharona and
drugs this is why and you're not
overstate it's a small effect but
teenage cannabis use has slightly fallen
in Colorado's legalization right so if
you are concerned to protect your kids
you want to get a pretty high priority
on getting it out of the hands of
criminals into the hands of licensed
businesses you have something to lose if
they sell to your kids I think it's
partly just explaining these things that
if people have a caricature of what the
alternative is if they think what we're
saying is hey everyone should be you
know kids should be using drugs people
should be using it while they're driving
division of course if that were the case
we would all be opposed to legalization
right yeah legalization is the opposite
of many of the things they say so I
think the job we have to do is partly
about humanizing the victims which is
amazing what you do and partly about
explaining what this war has been about
partly by explaining the harm of it and
just how much [ __ ] money it wastes
and about explaining what the
alternatives are in practice and in a
weird way this is gonna sound odd but in
a funny way
actually we agree about what we want the
drug laws to do in this country much
more than we agree on other things if
you stop the most right-wing you know
magic at wearing guy in Florida and you
said what do you want the drug laws to
do right most of them would say well we
don't want kids to use drugs we don't
want people to become addicted you go to
San Francisco and stop the most you know
liberal trans person on the street and
say what do you want the drug laws to do
most of them would say we don't want
kids to use drugs we don't want people
to become addicted we actually agree
much more than I don't know tax policy
we wouldn't agree on tax policy right
some people would say we want it to
create a more equal society some people
would say we want to
to unleash business you know there's all
sorts of perspectives on that right when
it comes to drugs we actually agree
quite a lot about what we want it to do
that once you once you go into the
conversation saying you know we actually
want the same things now we can have a
conversation about how do we achieve
those things and we can see we have not
achieved that pretty much everyone
acknowledges okay have we kept drugs
away from children look around you have
we reduced addiction we're in the middle
of the worst addiction crisis in the
history of the United States right now
there is some disagreement about
recreational drug use and obviously I'm
in strongly in favor of people having
the right to recreational use drugs we
have to be honest we don't agree with
right-wingers on that on a lot of them
but there's some really great
right-wingers on this you've been like
Senator Rand Paul the Cato Institute so
you don't want to it's not totally a
left-right thing but we have to be
honest about that disagreement but
actually there's a lot of agreement here
too hmm I think the only way to stop
drugs is that pain mm-hmm that's
brilliant
it is [ __ ] fucking-a I mean so many
people are in pain you know I don't even
know why yeah there's no doubt no I have
a son in 16 I started think it's still
mad and angry mmm yeah no doubt man I
think that's totally the core of it that
we've created a culture where more
people are in really deep pain it's not
that the past was so great and they
weren't serious roads because they were
right but whenever an addiction crisis
goes up that's an indicator of distress
in society and it always goes up in line
with suicide that isn't related to
addiction so that tells you it's obvious
suicide is so obviously an indicator of
distress and and it it doesn't go up in
so I tell you an example from history
that I think helps you to understand
what's happening in the u.s. now right
so in Britain in the 18th century huge
numbers of people were driven out of
their villages into these disgusting
like urban slums and places like London
and Manchester right they lost
everything that made life meaningful and
something happened in these slums which
was an outbreak of mass alcoholism it
was called the gin craze right and it
really happened there's a famous
painting from the time of like a woman
downing a bottle of gin while her baby
falls off of like a -
right and there really were like there
were bodies piling up in the street it
was a terrible thing and if you look at
what people said at the time they said
look at this evil drug gin look at what
it's done to us
if only we could get rid of gin this
problem would go away but now when we
look back we know it can't be gin that
caused that because anyone in Britain
can go and buy gin if they're over the
age of 18 and we've still got some
alcoholics of course but we don't have
bodies piling up in the streets
what changed exactly what you're saying
Mike it's not the availability of the
drug the drug is more available now than
it was then
what changed is the amount of pain in
the society and if you look at the
opioid crisis if it was just caused by
the drug there would be higher rates of
addiction in heart at the Harvard
faculty than there are in West Virginia
because people who work at Harvard have
really good health to insurance and will
get it eat find it much easier to get
hold of opiate based painkillers than
people in West Virginia in fact in West
Virginia the figures are just off the
scale right and they're relatively low
at Harvard there's not none but it's low
right what does that tell you the
addiction tracks with the pain and so
many of the things we're seeing that are
playing out around us are manifestations
of this deep pain so I would argue I'm
very much not a supporter of President
Trump but I would argue that the rise of
Trump is deeply related to this pain and
just screaming at his supporters at
their racists and their evil people is
deeply unhelpful right in the run-up to
the election I was in Cleveland with
these writing about these people who are
trying to get out the vote and we were
on this street and it was just this
devastated Street in West Cleveland at a
place called Slovak City where a third
of the houses were demolished a third
were abandoned and a third still have
people living in them and then I knocked
on a not on this we knocked on this door
and there's a woman who answered who I
would have guessed from looking at her
was 60 I discovered him talking to her
she was the same age as me I was 37 at
the time and she was quite articulate
she was really angry and there was no
way she was going to vote for Hillary
Clinton and and and and she made this
verbal mistake when she was talking that
really stayed with me she was talking
about what the area used to be like her
parents and grandparents they left
school when they were 16 they got good
jobs and she meant to say when I was
young
what she actually said is when I was
alive and it knocked me back and right I
thought this is how she feels and the
idea that in the wake of and I don't
misunderstand me I'm I'm strongly not a
supporter of President Trump in any way
but the idea that the solution is to go
back to this woman and just yell you're
a [ __ ] racist lady you're stupid
you've been do that we've got to just
like we've got to understand the pain of
people with addiction problems and
approach them in a spirit of love and
compassion we've got to approach people
who are behaving in other ways that may
seem dysfunctional to us and I do think
are harmful I do think the vote you know
I do think that vote was harmful um
we've got to understand whether if we
don't understand why things are
happening
we're just lost right and the problem
will just get worse and worse and I
think the one good thing about what's
happening all these interconnected
crises we're seeing diction suicide rise
of political extremism is the alarm is
going off right here the alarm we need
to stop a signal is being sent to us and
we need to stop insulting that signal we
need to stop acting like that signal is
just a sign of stupidity or craziness we
need to hear what it's telling us it's
and you're right Mike often people don't
know what that signal when you're in the
middle of the throes of the pain and
you'll see this in the way you do every
day when you're in the throes of the
pain it's not here to click it's not
easy to figure out what the signal is
row but this is telling us something
really important and if we just go back
to oh they're just crazy just for people
yeah that's not working that it's we're
gonna be heading to a much worse crisis
I must I must Runkle believing that they
need a lot of passion and love because
they hate themselves it is yeah exactly
dropping a whole bunch of [ __ ] on them
you know many labeled ago I won't do
anything love I give you an example of a
girl a really amazing group doing [ __ ]
to introduce you to these people
actually cause then I think you be
reassured this could be a great model
here in Los Angeles so in the year 2000
there was a homeless guy living in
Vancouver called Budd Osborne and at
that title it in a place called the
Downtown Eastside which has a huge
amount of homelessness and a lot of
chaotic Street use right and there was a
big police crackdown at the time
and bud was just watching his friends
die all around him one day he found out
a friend of his called Margaret had died
she in terrible circumstances had a
young baby and he's like I can't just
carry on watching my friends die but he
also is he would have put it there he
thought well I'm a homeless junkie what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do right and one day
bud had this idea it was kind of simple
because the police were cracking down
people would go and hide in order to
shoot up they would go into like dumps
that would go behind dumpsters or they
go into abandoned houses or whatever but
had this idea gathered together group
with the people with addiction problems
and he said let's just draw up a
timetable we won't have any officials or
anything just does and we'll go and look
in the places where we shoot up and if
someone is overdosing we'll call an
ambulance right because obvious if
you're hiding and you OD no one finds
you you just find your body hours later
right so they started to do this the
addicts drew up a timetable they start
searching these places and and over the
next few months the death toll on the
Downtown Eastside significant fall right
which was an amazing thing in itself
people who would have died were living
but it also meant the addicts started to
say you know maybe we're not the exactly
same like maybe we're not the pieces of
[ __ ] that we the people say we are maybe
we can do something so they stay formed
this group it's called van do the
Vancouver area network of drug users and
bad guy homeless guy had started this he
went to the local library and he learned
he was think about what could we propose
what can we do he discovered that in
Europe in Germany they had supervised
injection room so it's a place where you
can go and use your drugs and be watched
by nurses and doctors and be offered
help right and this had massively
lowered the deaths in Germany so he
thought okay we'll argue for that but
there'd been nothing like that in North
America for 70 years nothing even
comparable right he's like okay we're
gonna we're gonna fight for it the mayor
of Vancouver at the time was a guy
called Philip Owen who was a right-wing
guy who ran for office saying all
addicts should be locked up in the local
military base and never let out right
he wasn't like Trump he was a bit like
Mitt Romney he was a rich guy knew
nothing about addiction right and and
they're like okay we're gonna persuade
Philip Owen so they decided
everywhere Philip Owen went they were
going to follow him with a coffin and
the coffin had written on it something
like who will die next Phillip Owen
before you open a safe injection room
right every time
Phillip Owen
spoke in public anywhere someone with an
addiction problem stood up and said who
will die next Phillip Owen before you
open a safe injection site right one
time one of them Dean Wilson stood up
and said and do you remember Julia who
asked you two times ago who would die
next turned out to be her cause you
haven't [ __ ] done it right anyway it
went on for two years people got a bit
disheartened and then one day entirely
to his credit Phillip Irwin said what is
this who are these people right and he
went in sat with loads of the addicts he
got to know them it blew his mind he
didn't know anything about this right he
was blown away by how much pain they
were in how much love they could show
and he held a press conference and he
had who was it was the chief of police
the coroner and a representative of the
addicts
he said I'm never talking about
addiction again without having these
guys here with me we're going to open
the first safe injection site in North
America we're gonna have the most
compassionate drug policies in North
America things are gonna change around
here right and Phillip Owens right-wing
party was so horrified they deselected
him his political career ended but he
was but the guy they chose that gate the
guy ran against their candidate the kind
of more liberal guy won they opened the
safe injection site by the time I went
to Vancouver it was ten years since had
opened this site average life expectancy
in this neighborhood had risen by ten
years Wow because so many overdoses had
been prevented right you don't get
figures like that except when a war ends
it's an incredible and I remember going
to see Phillip Owen this mayor who'd
ended he told me it was the proudest
thing he'd ever done and he would
sacrifice his entire political career
all over again he said how many times in
your life do you get to save the lives
of thousands of really vulnerable people
and I mean but after I got to know bud
the guy who started this movement and
about died he was only in his early 60s
but he'd been a homeless addict during a
drug war it takes a toll on you and when
he died they sealed off the streets of
the Downtown Eastside where he'd lived
as a homeless person and they had this
incredible memorial service and there
were lots of people there who knew that
they were alive because bud had started
this thing and lots of people had joined
him and I remember thinking that day you
know it's very easy to get disheartened
about this right this is a hundred year
long war we're up against very powerful
forces everyone listening to your show
is more powerful than bud was that day
just by virtue of the fact they have a
device on which to listen to this
so right but didn't sit there thinking
ah this is too hard
he didn't sit there thinking someone
else is going to get this right
he started where he stood if you got
nothing else you've got a human voice to
persuade people around you
he started where he stood he appealed to
the goodness and the decency of the
people around him you know it led to
such a significant change that they had
this right-wing government in Canada
that tried to shut down the injection
site it went all the way to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court ruled that
addicts have a right to life which
includes a safe place to use drugs that
will never be taken away now right it
started with one person appealing to the
goodness of the people around them we
can win this thing right no one will
even defend this well one thing's very
striking one has to go on television to
talk about this they keep saying who
should we get to be the other side
because no one will go on television and
defend the war on drugs that's how
insane this policy is it has no
defenders and yet is the thing that your
governments spent a trillion dollars on
right so it's hollow we can bring it
down but we have to bring it down by
appealing to people's love and decency
and compassion yeah absolutely
so man we've been jamming I want to I
want to wrap it up with what are some
actionable items that people can take on
or commit to to help themselves find
more connection to help themselves have
greater sense of well-being and to make
their own impact in in the US and help
you know bring and bring an end to this
thing it has to one that pretty much way
they have to go to it no it's not coming
to them very much it's totally right and
that one of the things I learned is in a
way the struggle is the solution right
the act of coming together and saying
you know what this isn't a problem just
in me this is a problem in the way we're
living and the way we've been made to
live and fighting for something better
that alone is a really empowering thing
so I would say I would urge people to
support standing United and volunteer
with standing United but all over the
United States there are amazing groups
there's on the books websites www.hsn
the scream comm
there's a list of organizations people
can join and support us and and and and
and to fight on this because it's so
empowering to realize it's not a [ __ ]
and flaw in you right no problems in
your life of course in if there's
something much bigger going on here it's
not just mysteriously everyone in West
Virginia turned out to be you know
flawed in some way right that's not
what's going on here what was done to
West Virginia was a disaster right yeah
they were deprived and meaningful work
they were humiliated they were beaten
down and also by all sorts of forces
these acts of coming together and
realizing it's not you so I would urge
people there's a whole drug policy
alliance is an amazing group but there's
there's a huge range of things so it
depends what aspect of the issue you
most care about whether it's addiction
whether it's cannabis legalization as
they and there's a range of groups for
everyone you know I've just been
speaking to a evangelical Christian
group in Mississippi who were fighting
for drug policy reform right you can be
from all sorts of different places in
the spectrum on this and the drug war is
so bad that you can come from pretty
much any perspective row and see what a
disaster it is right yeah and so I would
yeah and I should just say can my
publishers always tumble don't say this
anyone who wants any more information
about anything's we've talked about you
can listen to audio of all the people
we've talked about like that the guys
died at Vancouver Bruce Alexander did
the rat Park experiment experts on
addiction and depression if you go to
WWE Haan for November and for November
har I comm Johann Hari dot-com and you
set my name right which now I once
waited for six hours with a broken arm
in an emergency room because they were
calling for Johanna Harry - so we've got
Johann Hari calm chasing the screamed
calm people get the audio book at that
yeah I love your book and the lost
connections calm is the one about
depression the lost connections about
depression and then standing United
amazing amazing to make your efforts
known there
I'm doing the hardest work right in the
trenches exactly you're doing that
building drugs work all over the world
you are in the hardest part and I just
admire that you can do it in such a
spirit of love and compassion is
important it's so inspiring to me thanks
awesome well thank you guys so much
thank you
ciao some guys till next time
parents all right peace Brigham thank
you
oh geez Mike thanks
[Music]